my colleague from nfl network nfl media
group who's been atop
this story of what's going on with so
many teams in covid 19 world in the 2020
nfl season tom pelissero joining me how
are you doing thomas
just swimming in the cove 19 waters once
again today i bet
so what's the what's the what's right
now at the top of the list is it the
jets and one player testing positive
uh today or being presumptive positive
what what are you telling me on that
what can you tell me here tom
well with the jets situation it's
important to understand the process that
goes into when you get a presumptive
positive so as i understand
it the timeline here is this is from
yesterday's round of the normal daily
pcr testing that everybody in the league
undergoes
every day those results come back late
at night or early in the morning
so when the result came back three
things happen under the protocols they
rerun the original sample
they give a rapid result poc test and
they do a new pcr test that's sent out
to a lab
well if the poc test and the pcr rerun
agree
then it's either confirmed as a positive
or confirmed as a negative in this case
they did not agree which is now why they
have to wait for this additional pcr
test
uh to confirm whether or not this
actually is a a real positive i know
that's a lot of acronyms in a short
period of time and i've learned just to
kind of throw them around
a little bit too liberally but point
being there are
many of these put it that way that
happen within the league some of them
end up being
confirmed there are many that end up uh
not actually being confirmed
the process to sort that out is a lot
faster because of what happened with
matthew stafford
back in training camp they accelerated
this process you no longer go
on the reserve covet 19 list and your
name isn't out there is having covet
before
uh the test is confirmed all of which is
to say
the jets are operating out of a phrase
that we've used a lot which is an
abundance of caution by sending
everybody home
right if in fact though this is shown to
be a false positive the team
and the player could be back to work
later today and so we wait
right and then you know we had dr alan
sills
on yesterday the chief medical officer
of the nfl um
there's uh videos that you can see and
watch and see
who this player was around as well as
the tracer that every player wears to
know
who this player was around and where and
who was massed up and who might not be
we'll get to the titans in a second so
there's a lot of ways that you go
you check the tape you check this you
check that and then you mentioned
that you rerun a test that's already
been run as well poc meaning point of
care it's done right there and then you
rerun
then you take a whole fresh new uh test
uh of the pcr test right now that's the
highly sensitive test that sills said
will pick up pretty much any particle
that might be considered
covid so that's all put together and
that's why the cardinals are still right
now planning on getting on a plane right
for this game as we're currently talking
right and that's just kind of the the
world that we're living in i mean
there's been i believe the numbers
released by the nfl earlier this week
because there's been 370 000 or so
tests run since camps began and you're
talking about
like 84 total uh new positive cases that
have taken place over the past couple of
months dating to
uh the middle of august i mean these are
these are very low numbers you have to
take each one seriously but
you know there have been 60 different
examples this season
in which there was a positive test
within a building
and it did not spread to anyone else and
i remember an executive for a team
telling me very early in this process
that
the greatest evidence that the protocols
work
is not when nobody gets it that might
just mean nobody was exposed it's when
one person gets it
and no one else gets it i spoke to
falcons coach dan quinn
uh last saturday and i asked him because
that was the same day that cam newton's
positive test came to life there was
changes to the patriots chiefs game
i asked quinn what did you learn from
the situation with aj terrell who the
previous saturday
had had a positive test the he was
isolated as you do under the protocols
no other falcons players had tested
positive and they played their game
without issue and quinn said it was two
things one
aj was really diligent with wearing his
mask and two
he had no violations on the traffic
report because every
team every day your trainer whoever it
is is communicating with the company
that reads
the tracking devices the connection
tracking devices and the data that those
put out
of were you within some six feet of
somebody for 15 consecutive minutes
if you were then you that is flagged ave
tarot didn't have anything i mean it's
it's an oversimplification on some level
but it really can be this simple at a
very base level which is
wear a mask and keep your distance and
you're not going to infect other people
even if you yourself end up getting
infected tom pelicero my colleague from
the nfl network nfl media group joining
me here
uh on the rich eisen show to discuss um
i uh let's move on right now
uh to the tennessee titans where do
things stand on on the titans
um playing their next game and also
the investigation as to why
there it appears the titans
players decided to hold their own
practices after
being told to go home tom well that's
what the nfl and the nfl pa have been
looking into and they have
reviewed surveillance video they have
conducted interviews i can tell you that
with people in the organization as well
as with players trying to get to the
bottom of
you know how did those unauthorized
off-site workouts and i'm told there are
multiple involving multiple position
groups
how did those come together i know
they've also looked into whether or not
masks were being worn consistently
they've looked into whether tracking
devices were worn consistently
and if violations are found it certainly
seems like at least on the work out
front then you would expect there's
going to be discipline
and potentially harsh discipline i mean
there's only been truly one
outbreak the patriots have had three
cases over the past week here
uh but the titans have had 23 over two
plus weeks
and the fact that you still had people
in the past couple of days in terms of
players testing positive
lends credence to the idea that there
was a continued
community spread after the facility
closed because the players continued
to get together on their own having said
all that
in terms of their ability to play this
game on tuesday i am told
there is a possibility that the titans
facility for the first time since
september 29th
could reopen as soon as tomorrow
afternoon they could be back
to work do a walk through maybe tomorrow
do a practice on sunday
you're ready to play on tuesday and even
if they have an additional positive test
uh it was emphasized to me today the nfl
is looking at the entirety of this
situation and i don't mean
roger goodell playing md here i'm
talking about dr alan sills
they have a committee of epidemiologists
to look at this as well as uh the
committee of former gm's and coaches and
players who are deciding some of the
competitive aspects of this there were
through the contact tracing a number of
titans players
that had identified as high risk close
contacts with some of the recently
infected individuals
so there is a likelihood if not an
expectation
that you will continue to have
additional positive tests in the coming
days
prior to that game on tuesday and the
same thing with the patriots there were
multiple i'm told
patriots players who have been
identified as close high-risk contacts
with stephon gilmore so again a
likelihood if not an expectation you
could have additional positive tests
but the league is not there's no hard
rule that if you have a test
on this amount before kickoff we have to
cancel it every situation is being taken
on a case-by-case basis
uh and they're doing what they can and
trusting the protocols
uh to try to make these games happen on
monday and tuesday tom pelissero here on
the rich eisen show it sure seems to me
tom
and again you're you're closer to it
than i am in terms of talking to league
sources and
you know becoming an expert on public
health that you probably never thought
you'd have to be to do your job
that the first three weeks of the season
where we just don't go about our
business not thinking about this as fans
that's over right that's that that
the nfl would be lucky signed for right
now that they will
hold another week in the nfl season
where all the games that are scheduled
are played on time
and every single team tests negative in
the same way that the first three weeks
happened would you say essentially we're
looking at the new normal for the rest
of the year
tom not necessarily just
based upon what the nfl and the nfl
pa believe happened uh in tennessee and
that's not to say that there was a
a concerted effort on the part of the
titans to violate the protocols or to
do anything untoward but there was a a
level of let's say
complacency that the league in the union
believes set in there
through which protocols were violated
and allowed
a virus to spread within the team that
had previously not spread certainly not
to this degree
within any other team so there was an
appeal made
on this past monday from the nfl to head
coaches general managers there were some
owners on a call
the message was very clear it was the
protocols
are not failing in some cases people
are failing so we all have a
responsibility
nobody can get complacent if we want to
actually finish this season
at the same time there has to be an
appeal made and some of this is going to
be coming from the clubs to the players
uh the players also cannot get
complacent that they have a role
nobody in all of this and you can say
what you will about
you know the hundreds of millions of
dollars that are at stake for nfl clubs
but
for players many of whom do not have a
hundred million dollars in the bank
uh you're running risks on multiple
levels if a season gets shut down
if the season stops if the games are
cancelled after this week
you stop getting paid you got paid
through five weeks your other 12 game
checks
are gone those don't come back and on
top of that
the impact on revenue would be so great
that there would be a ripple effect
on salary caps for years to come that
would cause players to be released that
would cause free agency
but for the top uh you know handful of
guys or
you know the top echelon guys would not
get as much money i mean
huge things at stake four players here
so you know maybe this is a reset point
the nfl i know there was some
speculation
are they going to pause the season at
this point could they take a week off
reschedule things into week 18 could
they even take two weeks off
shorten the season to 14 games uh at
this point again their
their focus right now is on finding ways
to have these games take place
and to do it in a medically sound way
and a big part of that
involves following the protocols and i
would also make this point rich yes
i was in green bay for the packers
falcons game
on monday night and if you've ever been
to green bay and flipped around the
local news stations
every head coach as long as i can
remember there has a series of kind of
these lo-fi
low-budget commercials for a variety of
different cable companies phone
companies whatever
matt lafleur has one that actually
looked pretty high budget it was all
about
wearing a mask and it was it was
starring him and i will tell you this i
was in
i was in the you know northeast
wisconsin for 48 hours
went into a handful of you know gas
stations restaurants whatever
and everyone has a sign on the outside
saying
mass required to come inside and in
every place
i would say many if not most of the
people were not wearing masks
so when mark murphy makes the
announcement that because of
uncontrolled spread because we're one of
the cobot 19 hot spots in the entire
country
we are not going to have fans in the
sands until
uh those numbers go down and until we
feel it is safe
that's an inevitable outcome uh you know
we can always have an intellectual
debate about
mortality rates and um you know the
strength of the virus
and all those types of things but listen
if you want
football to come back if you want a
layer of normality you have to take
these baseline type of precautions and
as we've seen in the nfl
the titan situation aside there's been a
lot of places there have been a lot of
infections
that have of people that have entered
the building but it hasn't spread to
others because they are following those
protocols
so you're saying again just about 90
seconds left you're saying
most of the people you saw in green bay
where
uh hospitals are overflowing and the the
governors
of the state said they have to build a
field hospital not wearing masks from
what you saw
so what you're saying i would say it is
fair to say repeatedly
i encountered people there certainly
were folks that did wear masks as well
but i would tell you
in every rest stop that i had to hit on
the way back to grab a coffee in boyd
wisconsin
or wausau or you know in the in the
greater green
area there were many people not
following
uh the mass mandate which again we can
we can talk about the reason we
talk about the virus we can talk about
the politicization
of science it's if you don't wear a mask
you are not going to have nice things
like fans in the stands at lambeau field
and
you know i've been to two games there
this year i've been to probably
i mean going back to my days with the
green bay press gazette 100 games in
that stadium
and it is a shame it's an absolute shame
that we're sitting there watching games
and you don't have roll out the barrel
you don't have you know the smell of
bratwurst and miller light as you're
walking through the parking lot it's too
bad no skull in minnesota and all that
stuff tom thanks for the time uh we'll
chat on game day morning
great work as always thank you sounds
good rich
that's tom pelicero